Today we're going to be looking at chapter three and this is pretty much about the newborn
and what can newborns do or not do and a little bit about how we physically develop in some
of our perception of motor skills.
Newborns are born with reflexes and the reflexes tend to fall into two categories.
Those that we have for survival value such as rooting and suckling and eye blinking.
If we didn't know how to do those kind of coming out of the womb we might have trouble
surviving.
Babies who don't have to suckle are a good example of babies who have a lot of trouble
Other reflexes may be ones that we need to have to begin to learn how to do other things.
So a great example is this reflex we have that we put a baby's feet down they pick them
up right away.
They pick them up right away and that seems to be a precursor to being able to walk learning
how to lift one's leg.
So they tend to be there for two basic reasons.
Reflexes are also very important to us in the healthcare industry because it really begins
to show us the health of the child.
The better the nervous system is the better the reflexes are.
We're going to want to measure those abilities as soon as they're born and there's a couple
of ways that we assess newborns.
Virginia Abgar created one of the more popular ones it's called the Abgar scoring system.
Now please ignore that little two I don't know why that's there but basically we rate
them on five different things heart rate, respiration, muscle tone reflexes in skin
tone and this would be basically a chart that you'd be given and you'd be giving them from
zero one or two points depending on how they react.
The total points tells us a lot about a child.
Now the magic number is seven we'd like to get a seven or better and then we know the
child is in excellent condition.
If they get anything less than a seven it's probably going to be that they're going to
need some sort of follow up more examination something that may need to be at least looked
at if it's really low down around zero three then we have a child who's in distress.
While the Abgar is very popular there are other assessment tools including the NBAS or
the needle needle behavioral assessment scale.
Now this one does use 28 different behavioral things that they're looking at but what's
different about this one versus the Abgar is that this one's really looking at your state
of mind, your alertness and your social interactions with other people.
How do you interact?
And you might say well newborns don't interact well yeah they do they they interact and just
stimulus affect them and other aspects like that.
As far as states newborns basically have four different states that they are.
We have the alert inactive and with the alert of active you can see this child is looking
at this particular person they're studying them they're wondering what's going on.
We also have the waking active where we're awake or active but we're not really looking
at anything in particular we seem to be unfocused with these uncoordinated movements.
Don't pretend like nothing's going on here it just simply we're not as attentive right
now we may be just processing information going on around us or maybe we're just digesting.
Crying is a state that I don't think I need to say too much about.
Most people know what crying is and sleeping is one that most parents would hope their
child would do for more than a few hours at a time.
We also have three basic cries when we are very little and we are talking about infancy
or basic cry the mad cry the pain cry.
Now we do know when children get older that they're going to have different cries in
this we are talking about the infant although my pictures are a little older than infants
I picked them for a very specific reason.
The basic cry is kind of soft to build some volume the child is hungry you know we see
sort of that face like this but the mad cry tends to be more intense and louder and one
of the differences between this cry and this cry is look at the forehead right here this
one is not very wrinkled here this child has got these eyebrows pushed together you can
see this is much more of a mad face than this is this is a pissed off little baby.
Pain cries are a totally different thing now one thing about pain cries is that even though
it says it starts loud it's followed by gasping we can also have pain cries that are quiet
meaning is that they absolutely have no volume coming out of them they are in pain and it's
a silent cry just a big empty hole and they still will gasp though in between those big
empty whole breaths.
We would love babies to sleep a lot and they do sleep a lot in fact they sleep 16 to 18
hours a day our only problem is that newborns only sleep about three hours at a given time
which is why most parents of newborn babies look exhausted but every three hours they wake
up for an hour and they want to eat why because it's that first year that we are growing so
much so we sleep we eat as I like to say we coo we poo that's all we do.
By three to four months we are in a little bit longer cycle we'll get five to six hour
cycles which is really nice and by six months we are sleeping hopefully through most of
the night and that's when parents begin to become less zombied.
What is very fascinating is that newborns spend most of their time in REM sleep about
50% of their time now that's unusual because as we get older that REM sleep goes down and
if you don't remember what REM is that's rapid eye movement and it's during rapid eye movement
that we have most of our vivid dreams so why are newborns having such vivid dreams well
if you remember from introduction psychology that first cycle of sleep tends to be our
processing dreams so one of the hypothesis is that newborns are just processing a lot
of what they're seeing throughout their day or what they've been exposed to so far.
After all they've had nine months but it's been a very protected nine months in that
mother's womb and when we come out all of a sudden the sights and sounds and touches
and feels these are all new to us so that all that needs to be processed in our very
small little brains.
Now temperament is basically a dimension of personality and one thing we know is that
our temperament tends to be there for the moment we're born.
Now don't confuse us with temper, temper is angry and all this temperament tends to be
one of many different things.
Now as it says here there's a debate on how many there are and we're not going to argue
how many there are but I do like to look at Rothenburg who looked at three dimensions
of children's temperaments or newborns, temperaments and the first thing is are these happy act
of vocal babies are they kind of extroverted or are they tend to be more quiet and less
active those are more innervated babies and you can see that pretty much from the moment
that a newborn is born then we have what they call the negative effect type of temperament
and that's anger, fear, frustration, shy.
These are children are not easy to be soothed, they scream and cry a lot and the last one
they look at is your effort to control you know how much are they controlling their impulses
at this area how much are they distractible and you know these are all things that tend
to stay with us sort of throughout our lifetime.
Question people often have is how much does our heredity versus our environment contribute
to our temperament and the studies they did were on twins.
Earlier two types of twins if you don't know there is identical twins which means one egg
is split and there are fraternal twins which have two separate eggs and but gestate at
the same time now in our twin studies we found that identical twins because they tend to
share the same DNA tend often to have very similar temperaments much more than fraternal
twins do but what we do find is that heredity tends to be more on that negative effect than
any other temperament dimension so the ones we said that they tend to be shy or quiet or
reserved.
We also know that heredity tends to contribute to temperament much more during childhood
than infancy so when they are babies we don't find heredity to be as much of a contributing
aspect we also find that things change over time.
So when we looked at this the question was as well we have this little baby who's been
born how stable is this temperament are we going to change a great deal as we grow up
and we do find is that they tend to be somewhat stable from infancy through adulthood and
then after adulthood we do find that we might have some changes.
Basically what we're talking about is that just because I have a temperament one way doesn't
mean that I'm going to be guaranteed to have that temperament always.
Just however can influence their child's temperament as they grow and what we're really talking
about here is maybe helping the child to either become more extroverted if they're too introverted
or maybe get more control or learn how to control their impulses it does mean we can
have enormously shaping our child and make them totally different person but we do have
some ability to go ahead and help a little bit with how that outcome may come.
Now growth is something that we need to understand growth in psychology or developmental psychology
is basically talking about the bones and the muscles where the use of the bones and muscles
is more about maturation.
So growth is very rapid we know in the beginning that any other time in our childhood and we
know that by time a kid is a year old they generally have tripled their weight we will
never triple our weight in one year again.
The other thing we need to understand that average is not the same as normal and so what
they mean by average is right here this red line on this growth chart is sort of the 50%
mark and most people say well that's the average child or that's not really the average child
it is the middle between the ranges but our thing is is that we can have a child of the
same age who have tremendously different height variances.
So if you happen to have a child whose ethnicity is one that tends to be toward the more petite
side such a Vietnamese heritage is often a very petite person versus somebody from an
area of Africa that's very tall you're going to see two kids who are basically the same
age who are going to have tremendously different height as far as who they are.
Now this can somewhat be a problem for the child because you can look here and say let's
say that we're right here at this height but we are this age.
So this is if I kind of scoot down this is 21 months but we're this tall.
So what could happen is that people could actually think that this poor 12 month old
is actually 21 months old so they could actually misunderstand the age of a child.
What's going to happen both ways children who are slightly more on the shorter side you
might want to say might be often viewed as being younger than children who are on the
taller side who are viewed as being older.
Now the older child the child who is viewed as being older is always assumed to be able
to do more whereas the child who is viewed as being younger often is frustrated because
people don't think they can do as much.
I've seen many cases where we have a child who is in the third percentile who's got a
good friend or the child who's in the 90th percentile and people will refuse to believe
that they're the same age even though they could only be a couple of months apart.
For you who are going into the field one of the things you need to do is begin to understand
that there is no common height as far as that's concerned.
What we are concerned about on these growth charts is if you are meeting basically this
curve what we are concerned with is if you're growing along the curve and then you kind
of don't meet the curve that's a signal to us that we need to start checking something.
Is there something wrong?
Why is this child gone off the curve?
Now in this case this is a boy curve.
There is examples in your book for both the boys and the females that you want to look
in.
But notice again maybe we're going along here and then we stop gaining weight.
That would be a sign that maybe something is wrong.
Now one time it's not a big deal unless there's a big drop but if there starts to be a trend
that you're not meeting the growth line then doctors will want to check into why that's
occurring.
We generally would say breast milk is the best milk for babies to help them grow.
However we also know that not everything can be done by the breast.
In some cases we may have to bottle feed.
Now you can take breast milk and put it into the bottle and thus you still have breast
milk for the bottle.
Other advantages and disadvantages to bottle feeding versus breast milk or during breasts.
One of the big things with bottle feeding is that this intimacy, this bonding time can
occur between the person feeding them and the child.
Now we will learn later on that this is more for the adult or for the person who's doing
the feeding than it is for the baby.
The baby bonding is just can you feed me because we were talking about infants here.
They're not really bonded to a specific person when they're this young.
But there are advantages and disadvantages to both, I'm not going to say one is better
than the other.
What I can say though is that we do try to get people who have got lower income to go
ahead and breast feed because there is no cost to that.
Once we start having to bottle feed quite often there are a lot more costs and a lot
more inconveniences with that.
By the time they're two the child's growth is really slowed down and quite often they
become much more finicky about what they want to eat.
The good thing is is that they still get all their nutrition generally.
Mostly what people will say to you if you're talking to some of the experts, we just try
to have the widest variety of diet that you can when the child is under two because the
more they're introduced to new foods and other items the more likely they'll be eating it
when they're two.
If they eat peas at one there's probably a good chance they're going to eat peas at
two.
The problem is that we tend to maybe not feed the best food when they're younger, a lot
of more french fries and we probably should.
Maybe a few potato chips we shouldn't feed.
I've seen, I have literally seen people give an 18 month old some soda.
We need to really look at what we're giving our children when they're young so that they
build a better appetite as they get older.
However, the other thing that you need to remember is that when they hit two, a lot of
changes are happening in their bodies and so foods that they may have liked before, they
don't like now.
They may have liked beets before and now they don't like beets and they'll tell you they
never liked beets.
Well, you have to forgive them a little bit.
They're two years old.
They don't really have the ability for memory and nor do they really have the ability for
time.
When they're saying I never liked beets, they're thinking about right now, I never liked beets
right now.
This is not anatomy and physiology class, so we're just going to go through this in general
just to make sure people have some basic knowledge of this.
In the brain, we know that the smallest system that we talk about are neurons.
Now, neurons consist of somas, dendrites, axons and terminal buttons.
This is a nice little picture, except for they forgot to mention that the soma is right there
in the middle.
The axon is basically a cable and it goes out to these terminal buttons.
You have to understand that information flows one way because it's an electrical current.
So an electrical current begins to build up here.
This charge and it charges down the axon and it goes out to the terminal buttons.
When that electricity gets out here to the terminal buttons, it stimulates the creation
of these things called neurotransmitters.
Now neurotransmitters are really fun little chemicals.
They float across the synaptic gap and they go into the next neuron basically here at
the dendrites.
Neurotransmitters are exactly what they say.
They transmit information from one neuron to the other.
And depending on the type of neurotransmitter, it would depend on the information being transmitted.
Serotonin is the happy one.
I like serotonin.
It makes you feel good.
You get it when you eat chocolate and other things.
Just one reason why we all should have chocolate every day.
But serotonin is the feel-good one.
It's the one that could be stimulated if you're depressed.
They may give you something to help you increase your serotonin.
Neurotransmitters we're going to talk a lot more about as we get further into the text.
But we do need to understand that the flow of information is one way.
It's electrical within the neuron.
It is chemical between the neurons and the synaptic gap is going to become a very important
function and the receptor sites are going to become more important as we grow.
We understand that when we're little, we have very few neurons and as we begin to grow from
empathy through our first year of life, through our third year of life, fourth year of life,
we begin to develop a tremendous amount of synapses.
Remember, I said our brain is kind of soft and squishy when we start and now our brain
is going to get wired basically.
Specialization in the brain occurs pretty early.
We need to begin to organize the brain, you might say, as a newborn.
So we see many different things that happen in our newborn stage that we're not going
to see later on such as a great emphasis in electricity in the left side of the hemisphere
in response to speech.
Now, as we get older, what begins to happen is that we're going to take that area that's
going to be dedicated to language and instead of using electricity all over that brain,
we're going to begin to find that it gets narrowed down and narrowed down to the specific
area of the brain that's going to be concentrating on language and thus other things that might
have been there are going to get pushed out.
So maybe in the area that we're going to have language, when we were first a newborn, we
also had leg movement.
Well, leg movement is going to get pushed to someplace else and this area of the brain
is only going to be for speech, which also tends to find that that area that's stimulus
will then tend to stimulate that area of the brain to even develop more.
We need to do is wire.
Remember the synapses that I talked about?
Well, we're born with very few synapses and as we experience things and as we do things,
we begin to develop more synapses.
We also know that we're going to start on the lower functions of our life, basically
our senses and perceptions and if you think about that, that would be the first things
that we need to make sure that we understand and that our brain can function before we
start into higher order things like thinking.
I basically have to understand eating, I have to understand breathing, I have to understand
all those things before I can think about math.
Now, environmental stimulation is successful for two kinds of specialization, both are
based on experiences.
Now expectant growth is one where we say we expect every child to be able to do this.
So, faces are something that every child around the world will begin to experience and we
see a growth of knowledge of what faces are.
Now, dependent growth basically says that this is something that's unique to the individual.
So, in this case, I'm an individual who happens to have a parent who plays music and so I'm
beginning to learn piano, I see my parents play piano, so I experiencing the development
of my brain of learning how to play the piano.
Now, another child is not going to experience that, thus my brain has got that very specific
development.
We talked about plasticity before, but let's make sure we remember what plasticity is.
It's basically that the brain is very flexible and allows recovery of functions, especially
in young children.
What we're talking about here is that because the brain hasn't specialized yet, because
the brain is still forming, we have the ability, if something goes wrong, to basically have
another air-the-brain take that over.
Now, as we get older, that can be harder to do.
So, if it's a young child who's had maybe some damage in, in this case we say the speech
area, we may find another air-the-brain takes that responsibility over because it hasn't
been formalized, it isn't specialized yet.
Whereas, with an adult, our brain is already specialized, so if I lose my ability for some
speech, I may not have another air-the-brain that can take that over.
As children, we need to begin to coordinate our skills.
And what we're talking about is component skills.
And what component skills are are little things we need to be able to do before we do the big
thing.
So, we need to be able to sit up, we need to be able to sit by ourselves if we're being
held with something before we can sit alone.
And that's basically what they're talking about with development over time.
We look for these stages or these coordinating component stages.
And we need to be able to integrate those together.
Now, that can be really difficult, as we say.
Infants are very top-heavy in the beginning and boy, can they lose their balance.
But what's really nice is very quickly we begin to develop our inner ear, we begin to
develop some visual cues, and boom, we basically learn balance.
And then by seven months old, most infants can sit up by themselves.
Well, the same thing is applied to locomotion.
We have little steps that we have to take before we can walk alone.
Now, it does say walk alone here at 15 months.
And I will usually get somebody who says, "Well, my child walked at nine months," or
"mine did this."
Well, we talk about walking in a couple of different ways.
You know, there's walking when you're led by the hand, and yeah, we can see kids doing
that younger.
Generally, when we talk about walking here, we're talking about unsupported independent
walking where they don't fall down after two steps, or where they go down because they
want to go down, not because they've lost their balance to go down.
Generally, this is somewhere between 12 months and 15 months of age.
Now you notice it says walk alone by 15 months.
Remember, we talked about that when we see something like that, what we're talking about
is that most children by 15 months can do this.
However, some children we're going to say are doing this younger, and some children may
still be taking this longer.
Generally, for almost everything, there's a range of when a child can do this.
Now, the reason we say something like walk alone by 15 months, because if they aren't
walking alone by 15 months, or they aren't pintering by 12 months, or they aren't sitting
by seven months, we then want to maybe go in and do a little investigation on why they're
not doing that.
This becomes a signal that there may be something wrong.
It doesn't mean there absolutely is, because remember babies develop at different rates,
and so you could have one child who is just simply taking a little longer to walk.
When we say a range, we could take it until 18 months to walk, and as long as we're walking
by 18 months, we're fine.
It's like teeth, most kids have got teeth before they're 12 months old.
However, if you don't have a tooth by the time you're 12 months old, it's still okay.
We don't really get worried about not having teeth until you're 14 months old, so a child
who doesn't have a teeth at 12 months, what do they want for their birthday?
A tooth.
But we're not too worried.
We might take x-rays if they haven't showed a tooth by 12 months to make sure that they're
forming and that they've had enough calcium and things are going well.
These are ranges to help spot if there's a problem.
Find motor skills tend to talk about the hand, and I've made just this nice little chart
for you to kind of look at, to kind of understanding some of the skills that you might have at
different ages using a rattle, so when we can briefly hold a rattle versus when we can take
that rattle and start hitting a cup with it.
These are find motor skills, and we develop them over time.
I've always thought it was interesting that about 90% of children prefer their right hand,
but we really won't know if they're right-handed until basically nine months, somewhere eight
to nine months over here, it shows our hand preference.
So if we have a child who at eight or nine months is still using their left hand all
the time, then we may have a lefty.
But if your child is five months old and they're using their left hand a lot, it doesn't mean
they're going to be left-handed.
Really won't know until about nine months.
And by the way, handedness can also be a cultural issue.
We know that there were a lot more right-handed people in the United States in the 1950s because
basically any child who was left-handed was told they had to learn how to be right-handed,
and they were taught only to write with their right hand in school.
And so many lefties actually turned into being right-handed writers.
People like my mother turned out to be ambidextrous.
She could write with both her left and her right hand.
Now we also know that culturally things like cutting your food can be taught differently
to different people.
In the United States, generally, we use the fork in the right hand.
But when we're going to cut meat, what will happen is we'll switch our fork to our left
hand and then use the knife in the right hand.
What's interesting is that in Europe, the children are not taught to switch their fork
around.
They keep their fork in their right hand and they're taught to cut with their left hand.
It is a skill.
You can learn to do it either way.
But it is a skill.
And so some of these fine motor skills are taught to us, you know, when we talk about
handedness, it's taught to us by what does our culture say.
But we're not going to really see generally until about nine months whether or not a child
is going to be a left-year or righty.
And even then, we may have to wait a little bit.
Now some of you have read ahead, and one of the things you may find interesting is that
children really don't learn to tie their shoes until about six years of age.
The funny thing on that one is because children don't tie their shoes until about six years
of age and people are looking for things that are more convenient and letting children be
more independent and because parents get tired of tying their child's shoelaces all the time,
there are more and more shoes coming out without shoelaces, they're using elastics and other
things.
Well, this has resulted in that there have been many people growing up to be 18 years
of age who really never had to tie shoes because their shoes are already sort of pre-tied.
What's funny is that the US Army recently had to add in a workshop on how to tie your
shoes because they've had recruits coming in who've never had to tie their shoes.
And so they have to teach them how to tie their boots.
Another thing that of course is happening at this age is getting to understand our smell
and taste and this is all about perception.
Now I'm going to define this word here because sometimes when we use perception, we may be
using it in a different way than we might in this class.
For us, perception is about processing sensory inputs and it's receiving, modifying, organizing,
but it's all about our sensory inputs.
How do we perceive what we see, hear, feel, or touch?
That is what it is.
As a little child, as an infant, we're beginning to develop a lot of these things.
So how are newborns?
Well, newborns are really sensitive to odor.
They understand pleasant and unpleasant things and they're also very sensitive to taste.
They can taste the difference even in their mother's breast milk.
So if mom's eating a lot of garlic today, maybe you can tell it and maybe you may or may not
like it.
That's why sometimes you find babies are a little fussy some days about drinking the
milk and not drinking the milk.
It doesn't happen as much with formula because formula tends to be more formulated, being
the same each time, but it's also why babies don't like to change formulas.
This is the lemon test down here.
It's always kind of fun to watch kids try lemons for the first time.
It's a very sour taste and it ranges from happiness to absolute ooh, yuck, can't stand
it.
What are you doing to me?
When we talk about pain, we have to talk again about the crying.
Crying is just absolutely linked to pain.
One of the big things about this is that remember they not soothe very well when they're in
pain.
And so if you have a baby who is crying and crying and crying, that loud wailing crying
or gasping mostly is what you want to watch and your soothing isn't working, then they
may be in pain and it may be time to take them to the doctor.
Anybody who's had a baby who's got an earache knows that they just cry because they're in
pain.
They don't have to tell you this, but you do want to begin to understand the difference
between the two different cries pissed off versus pain.
The CDC, the Center for Disease Control and Prevention really recommends that almost all
child gets a hearing test within the first month of age.
Most kids get their hearings tested right when they're born in the hospital and they
say little devices they put on them.
You can see it's just a little something that goes over the ear, it's a little thing
that goes here.
This little monitor is saying whether or not the brain is receiving signals from the ear
over they send little tones in.
We want babies of course to be able to hear and if for some reason this monitor does not
show that they're receiving signals, we're going to want to very quickly begin to do
some more testing to see if the problems within the ear, if the problems within the
brain is the problem between the connection between the ear and the brain and the faster
we can understand what's wrong, the faster we can come up with therapies or responses
to that.
The child who can hear normally who has no problem with their hearing generally by four
months of old do seem to recognize their own names so we know that very quickly hearing
and that specialization of the brain is taking place.
With seeing one of the interesting things is that we know that newborns are born with
these big eyes and what most people don't realize is that the eyes of a newborn are already
75% of what they're going to be when they're adult so our eyes don't have a lot more growing
to do once we're born.
Not only do human babies have this but we also can see this in the animals of kittens
and dogs and many animals.
It tends to want to make us want to take care of them.
We see them as being vulnerable when they've got those big eyes so we think in part that
development of having these very large eyes or 75% of our normal size was a way for babies
to get attention and so it worked well so it continued to be something that was passed
on from generation to generation.
We do know that by the time a child is a year old they basically the same visual acuity
as an adult but before that no not so much really when we're an infant about a month
old we don't see very well at all 20 feet is about the best we can see.
Basically most of our vision between the arm, the nook of the parent who's like holding
the child to feed them and the face is really their best visual area when they're newborn
so they can concentrate on that face.
It's quite often why they're staring at faces while they're being fed because they can really
see that and we're also know that they're getting their color is developing also over
this time.
This perception is this interesting area a lot of science has been put into this and
they've done what they call the visual cliff research and basically it's a cliff however
there's a piece of glass that goes over it and of course the baby is perfectly safe.
Normally it's red and white and basically what they're trying to find out is when does
a baby begin to understand depth.
Now you can see this baby is crawling right across the glass has no fear probably this
baby doesn't understand depth at this point whereas this child is coming up and gone now
I'm not going any further it looks like I could fall.
Even with encouragement from the parent the child doesn't move which means by this time
they're beginning to show some fear and that's generally about seven months.
What's kind of interesting is a lot of that fear also tends to develop about the same
time that a child can crawl.
This may have been a survival thing to allow children to begin to realize who are crawling
away that they shouldn't be crawling into holes because if we don't have death perception
we would know whether or not we could safely crawl somewhere.
By the way I love this little picture from American science they put this on there.
They actually tested whether or not other animals had the same thing and we did discover
that kittens and other animals did the same thing at first they'd walk straight across
the glass and at some point they stopped to look over and went nope I'm not walking across
because they had a fear of falling.
Faces are an interesting thing when we get to the the Toy Store next week or whatever
week we go we talk a lot about faces on toys why because we know that children can begin
to understand faces very quickly the two eyes the nose and the mouth and by six months we
can already begin to prototype what a human and non-human face is by six to twelve months
we actually know only do we understand what faces are but we begin to recognize the faces
that are familiar to us versus the ones that are not familiar how do we know this because
we know that children tend to want to look at faces that are familiar to them.
Parents faces friends faces and they tend to look away when it's a face they don't understand
or don't know.
The last section of the book is kind of an important section it's one that on the test
I asked quite a few questions on.
This is about becoming self aware and there are kind of three things I want to make sure
you get out of this the first one is you know when do we begin to realize that we exist
that that face that I see in the mirror is actually me and toddlers and preschoolers what
are their self concepts like how do they define themselves and when do we begin to acquire
something called theory of the mind when do we begin to relate our thoughts to our actual
behaviors well the self aware concept and how we developed self awareness and our belief
in this was do this thing called the red rouge test basically this was kind of an interesting
thing we have a mirror set up and the question is whether or not this child could understand
who's that in the mirror when they're younger they don't get that that's them in the mirror
they think it's another baby and when that baby smiles it makes them smile which makes
the baby smile and it's just a nice funny round robin what we did do is we took these
babies and we the mothers would play within the babies would be looking at them and then
somehow without the baby knowing it we put this red dot on them either on their nose
or their forehead and then maybe we'd go back to look in the mirror and most babies tried
to clean off the red dot from the mirror meaning is that they thought this other child had a
red dot on them at some point when we put the red dot on them in this case there's a red
dot on the nose when the child begins to wipe off their own nose then we know they understand
that that face the mirror is actually them and that wiping the red dot off of this is
not going to help because as a reflection that they want the red dot gone they have to wipe
it off their own nose that happens somewhere between 15 and 24 months but by 24 months
most all kids understand that that reflection in the mirror is their own which means as toddlers
they begin to want to look at photos of themselves so photo albums of yourself is something that's
really interesting to little kids because they now understand that that person in the
picture is me and they want to see what I looked like when I was a baby you quite often find
them getting very interested in babies and what are babies because they're beginning to realize
that that baby that picture they say is them we also begin to see toddlers beginning to
use the word I so they're good at getting understand that this is them in the picture
I want to do this I want to do that but they also tend to show an awareness of the past
I did this yesterday I did this two days ago so they're beginning to understand that that
they're in a time frame they're not so good on future but they're pretty good with the
past we also know that toddlers are very much into their possessions their possessions basically
define who they are I am my possessions my possessions are me which is one reason why
the terrible twos are called the terrible twos they don't like to give things up with
preschoolers we get a little bit more sophisticated generally preschoolers are older than two they're
three or more and they do start adding things like fear physical characteristics in and
some preferences so they may define themselves as a kid who likes Spongebob and likes this
particular blanket that blanket is mine and I'm a Spongebob fan and I've got dark hair
that may be how they begin to describe themselves it's really too much more adulthood that we
begin to describe ourselves as far as our likes and our beliefs and our values so little
kids yeah not there basically it's mine now the theory the mind says when do kids begin
to understand that their mind is actually controlling their behaviors and their behaviors
are controlled by their mind and there's sort of a three phase approach to this notice
that phase one happens about two years of age why well we have to get to the point where
self-aware remember self-awareness happens at two so when we become self-aware we also
begin to be aware of desires that are in us that this little voice sort of in our head
or whatever sound that's in their head that desire I can actually begin to do something
about so if I desire a cookie I can speak out that I want that cookie and maybe I'm going
to get that cookie so I begin to get aware that that my mind and my desires they're all
connected and that I can kind of control things and by three we understand that there's a
difference between what I'm mentally thinking versus what's physically happening be outside
with me so I will use those words like I think this or I believe this and they understand
that just because they think it doesn't mean that it's going to happen they understand
that thinking is inside the head that that voice inside their head is they are not on
the outside by four years of old they begin to know that their behavior can be based on
a belief about an event and what we're talking about here is that if I believe that Christmas
I believe at Christmas I'm going to get happy and that event is going to cause me to want
to jump up and down and run and scream I understand that what they also say is that by four years
of age we understand even if a belief is false so somebody tells you something we begin to
understand that can't be true so this is the example your book has about the false belief
example this is basically the story that goes on a little child is told that there is Sally
and Annie Sally has a basket and Annie has a box Sally decides to put her ball in her
basket and then Sally goes out to play while Sally is gone Annie takes the ball out of the
basket and puts it in her box and then Annie decides to go to the kitchen when Sally comes
back in from playing where will Sally look for the ball will she look for the ball in
her basket will she look for the ball in her box now a young child is going to say she's
going to look for the ball in her box because they understand the balls in the box what they
don't get was that Sally didn't know that when they get to be about four years of age when
asked the same question they will say Sally will look for the ball in the basket because
they understand that that's where Sally last sought thus that's where Sally probably would
go back to look for because she doesn't know it got changed so it's kind of interesting
this false belief example that we take until about four years of age to kind of understand
that well this is the end to this lecture I will happily see you in class and we will
move on to the next chapter next week.